jacques chirac et dominique de villepin
assisteront jeudi soir à paris à la
cérémonie à la mémoire d'ilan halimi à
la grande synagogue de la victoire
la présence des deux plus hauts
personnages de l'exécutif devrait donner
un caractère national à ce rassemblement
dix jours après la mort du jeune vendeur
enlevé et torturé
l'enquète continue sur le gang des
barbares en france mais aussi en côte
d'ivoire où se trouverait le chef
présumé
le point avec jeanne assouly le gardien
de l'immeuble où ilan halimi a été
séquestré est poursuivi pour complicité
de séquestration en bande organisée
ils auraient sous-loué en cachette cet
appartement où le jeune homme a été
retenu et torturé pendant deux semaines
ils auraient facilité l'accès à la
chaufferie de l'immeuble où la victime
serait probablement resté une semaine
avant d'être abandonnée agonisante dans
l'essonne le gardien dit ignorer ce qui
se passait dans l'immeuble il a été mise
en examen et incarcéré mercredi
au total 13 personnes ont été mises en
examen
onze d'entre elles ont été placées en
détention provisoire par ailleurs deux
personnes ont été interpellées mardi en
région parisienne trois autres suspects
sont maintenues en garde à vue à aix en
provence et à marseille
les cinq personnes devrait être déféré
en fin de semaine mais le chef de gang
présumé court toujours
youssouf fofana serait en côte d'ivoire
abidjan
sur place deux enquêteurs français
assistent leurs collègues de la police
judiciaire ivoirienne il aurait une
piste un homme portant le même nom que
le principal suspect aurait séjourné
dans cet hôtel
jeudi soir une cérémonie aura lieu à la
mémoire d'ilan halimi à la grande
synagogue de paris jacques chirac et
dominique de villepin y assisteront